Привет! Это последний урок модуля System Architect. Сегодня закрываем модуль и ставим курсовой проект.
В результате модуля у нас в Figma собран сквозной кейс облачного хранилища. Внутри информационная
архитектура, юзерфлоу, дизайн-система с фондейшн и UI китом, четыре финальных экрана с привязкой к компонентам,
отдельно собранный лендинг через Cloud Design, прогон аудита без критических находок. Это путь от пустого
проекта до собранного MVP на сквозном продукте. Тот же путь теперь мы делаем на твоём проекте — это
и есть курсовая работа модуля. Курсовая работа — это твой продукт из исследовательского модуля,
проведённый через весь маршрут System Architect. Бриф, исследование Job to be done,
продуктовые гипотезы с предыдущего модуля — это вход для текущей работы. Цель — собрать MVP проекта
с Figma, возможно, MLP, тут уже что тебе посоветует агент. Каркас продукта с дизайн-системой,
ключевыми экранами, на основе которого можно идти дальше, наполнять визуальным контентом и собирать
прототип. Курсовая закрывает два модуля вместе. Исследовательский дает продуктовое понимание,
System Architect превращает его в работающий интерфейс. Что должно быть собрано к моменту сдачи?
Во-первых, информационная архитектура, сайтмэп, основные юзерфлоу, также варфреймы, каркас,
ключевых экранов. Обязательная страничка Foundation с примитивными и семантическими переменами,
с описанием вообще твоей дизайн-системы. Также должен быть UIKit не менее 12 компонентов с состояниями,
размерами, с предусмотренными вариациями и так далее. Все то, что мы делали в течение модуля.
Конечно, там должны быть кнопки, поля ввода, карточки. Все самое основное и необходимое,
что у тебя точно в проекте будет. Что сверху этого, конечно, уже зависит от продукта. Эти
компоненты вполне могут вместе с экранами добавляться в ходе твоей работы. Это абсолютно нормально.
Именно те, что твой агент определил как MVP, как самое главное, если у тебя агент MVP по
каким-то причинам не определял, можешь это сделать в любой момент, работая над курсовым проектом. Можешь
и сам определить, что для тебя будет MVP. Главное, чтобы это был понятный и живой продукт с
последовательностью экранов, с возможностью все этапы пройти. Опять же говорю, мы не собираем
сейчас прототипы, будем делать это потом. Нам сейчас нужно выстроить такую систему, в которой все
для этого будет. Также продукты у вас могут быть вообще совершенно разными, но лендоз для презентации,
продажи этого решения, этого продукта - это в целом очень распространенная практика. Поэтому,
Cloud Design, по желанию, если у продукта есть маркетинговая часть, пожалуйста, делай. Если это
внутренний инструмент или какое-то закрытое приложение, окей, можешь пропустить. Также проводим
аудит обязательно, убеждаемся, что никаких критических ошибок нет, если они всплывают, то разумеется,
фиксим. Актуализируем тем самым аудитом Composition Map, то есть все, что у тебя есть в
фигме, должно быть в твоей среде описано в качестве вот этих MD файликов, которые агент создает для
себя. Обязательно наша система по итогу всей этой работы должна быть логичной, понятной, актуальной и
взаимосвязной. И что самое главное вообще в принципе в подходе именно к курсовому проекту. На
сквозном кейсе мы шли по принципу достаточно для демонстрации, для того, чтобы понять, как это
работает. Один прогон директивы, минимальная доводка, едем дальше, так и положено для обучения
механики инструмента. В курсовом задача другая: мы симулируем реальную работу над продуктом. Что это
значит на практике? Первая итерация агента - это черновик. Дальше с ним работаешь, доводишь,
не отправляешь сразу первый результат на следующий этап. В общем, делаем так, как мы делали бы на
настоящем проекте. Также отдельно еще раз отмечу: общайся с агентом, не бойся обсуждать, иду,
уточнять, возвращаться к уже сделанному. Если тебе кажется, что собранная карточка плохо ложится
в твой экран, скажи ему об этом, переформулируй задачу. Если на финальном экране что-то не так с
композицией, обсуди, попроси переделать это совершенно нормально. Таким образом, мы дообучаем агента
его память растет, и он делает все лучше и лучше. Углубляйся в продукт, расширяй его,
описывай агенту, что тебя не устраивает, что он делает хорошо. Это позволит прийти к хорошему
результату. Каким будет удовлетворительный результат, если продукт собран и выдерживает
твою же собственную критику? Если ты смотришь на это и готов сам сказать, что да, это завершенная
полноценная работа. Итак, какие у нас сроки? Срок на разработку курсового проекта у нас неделя. Учитывая, как
сильно агент ускоряет всю нашу работу, этого точно будет достаточно. Формат сдачи, как обычно,
просто ссылка на твой Figma файл. Внутри, разумеется, должны быть фундейшн, компоненты, экраны и так
далее. Все, что было у меня в уроках. И теперь немного затронем следующий модуль. Мы уже прошли от
трех строчек брифа до полноценного MVP Figma с помощью искусственного интеллекта. В следующем модуле
Visual Engineer мы наполняем продукт визуальным контентом. Иллюстрации, фотографии, видео,
генерация бренд-ассетов, placeholder, плашки у нас будут заменяться на реальное содержание.
Возможно, не в каждый продукт будет куда всунуть какой-то визуальный контент, но если к своему
продукту ты делаешь лендинг в Cloud Design, его можно будет как раз этим контентом наполнить.
На этом все. Удачи с выполнением курсового проекта и до встречи в следующем модуле.